home for me first of all is a peace of
mind where you come home and you're
always safe
that's what home means to me especially
for my children
before i moved into this home six months
ago i was living in a shelter to get my
own home it was just breathtaking but
there was nothing in it
i am kristen suite and i am a designer
at humble design
everything in this warehouse you see is
donated
we work with homeless and domestic abuse
shelters with families that are moving
out of those shelters and into homes and
a lot of times they have nothing but the
clothes on their back that's where we
step in and we provide the furniture for
them but then we also go back and
decorate and provide like those little
details that make your house a home and
makes it your home
without our help about 46 percent of
families coming out of the shelter go
right back in with our help that
statistics goes down to one percent
i'm a direct care worker and i work with
older elder people
before i lived in the shelter the
boyfriend that i was living with was
emotionally and physically abusive to me
one day i woke up and i just said i
wasn't taking that anymore
today we met with danielle and we just
talked
with her a little bit found out about
her backstory it sounds like she has
come out of the shelter and now has been
in a house with basically no furniture
she has a few pieces but no beds no you
know chairs no table
so we talked with her a little bit about
what she wants in her home we went to
the the home we took measurements
and just walked through each room
what dinner looks at my house now we all
sit together but we sit on the floor the
priorities was to have like silverware
bowls and spoons stuff some things for
us to eat out of and
bedding to put on the floor for us
because we didn't have beds
when i first started here i didn't
realize that people were living this way
when you walk into a home that is
completely empty and families are living
there and have lived there for months
it's shocking because you don't think of
it
but on that friday when we reveal a
house i just i just love the energy
from our volunteers to the families that
are getting these you know
new homes really
um
i just i can't get enough of that
feeling and that's why i've stayed here
for for so long
i know my kids are going to be amazed
because i haven't really told them
what's going on i just told them they
was getting some beds so they don't even
know that the whole house is going to be
done so i know they're going to be
astounded
so it just makes me very happy
it's like a
magazine from zero to a miracle
i love y'all for this i mean this is
amazing
it's just happiness to me to be able to
walk into a home and have your friends
and family there and you're able to just
show them comfort enjoy that means a lot
to me and i hope that one day i can give
back just what was given to me
you